hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to IM bread now I've
calmed down a bit
I have relaxed I have slept I have eaten
and I think I'm ready to go back into
this with an open mind and an open heart
because that's what it takes to beat
this game and my hope is that I'm gonna
get better at this as time goes on
become toast where am I
why can't all well OH
ah okay I can deal with this
flying blind I hope I'm doing it right
oh I don't know how I haven't you
delicious news oh oh yay hey okay oh
there we go all right where am I going
let me get a lay of the land here a
nudge nudge God that doesn't that oh my
god are you all okay can you just bend a
little more and get on the lid that'd be
great
[ __ ] hell oh okay you're not gonna
[ __ ] you okay Wow there we go
snick snack the way back I don't know
what that means but everybody ignore
that oh furnace is that what I'm
supposed to do okay I can do this
whoo I can do this okay okay
oh okay oh where am i oh hi okay pull
I'm down and up oh that's not what I
want to do how about you get normal okay
yeah okay well I went absolutely nowhere
there was no point in me doing any of
that great I'm so happy that I did that
in my life alright so what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna attempt to throw myself off
of this ledge over there I believe I can
get better leverage if I toss myself
from here oh whoa nailed it don't be
ruch to me oh this is this is jiggly
douche huh oh why okay Oh God
we're fine whoop whoop whoop
ah oh this is not what I wanted okay
that's that not how I would physics up
trouble okey now the test oh come on oh
wow oh yes oh I don't know what I did
but I did it good so this is going much
better than last time like I thought I
would
I've steadily gotten better at this not
great mind you bought Bow Wow
better badder better okay oh I'm fine
okay so I gotta throw myself OH
from here to there oh okay oh okay oh
God oh I'm fine everything's fine how
are you cold
hahaha okay alrighty then we're doing
great
oddly enough boy I love the one I can't
see where I'm going
that's of my favorite thing huh hey
how's it going there friend you're gonna
be friendly to me I will you will death
hmm hey it's fine
ha ha ha hey okay not what I wanted I'll
accept it okay all right I know what I
want oh oh all right so far so good I
don't know what I have honey
Oh God why do I have tape on me huh oh I
thought that wall was gonna be deadly
but apparently not shockingly we are
fine huh
we are not toast but we're fine oh hey
oh that was severe slippy territory so I
told you no i'ma go the other way I like
the other way better feels good
we're fine he's good I'm making good huh
grabbing on with all my body so I made
it this far this far thus far this
doesn't seem like it was gonna be too
hard why is there blood on that ironing
board I don't know haha oh cool right
okay all right okay so there's probably
some sort of a control mechanism here
that I got a turn on before I can do
thing oh hey hi just want to be down
here how you doing oh I can grab nothing
I can grab now I can grab nothing Oh
none of it's gonna work Oh Oh none of it
Oh
oh that that's great I'm uh okay alright
then that's an option what are you okay
no I nail this
uh-uh oh okay
well that was the bad but we turn it on
do I sing it sweet nothings oh oh oh oh
oh no okay
I don't know where a whole cameras
you'll do that to me okay not that this
is any better but I have this now and
I'm here oh great oh great
oh great oh great Oh slap your meat on
there oh oh come on my grip my grip my
grip McGirt oh no no [ __ ] no oh god
dammit I can't grab the grill
[Music]
that was a long way to go for a whole
lot of nothing
I don't know where I am but I'm gonna
blindly go where no bread has gone
before
oh oh okay ah righty-ho then okay woo
hey whoa yai oh [ __ ] me then oh how I
did this
plop all right I like life and I like
living life and live oil and wife agree
hahahaha oh come on oh oh I hate toast
oh God
I ain't right oh no uh-uh
Oh No oh yeah on oh yeah there we go
oh no okay oh oh just lay down ma'am
sir oh now I had it Oh clam jam I can't
turn much else on but I'll try turn this
on yeah okay how do I grab that okay all
right not Annie
that ain't right whoa whoa okay oh okay
okay
ha ha ha oh no I meant bit bad I wasn't
touching here god the camera why is the
camera so bad oh god the camera oh oh
you know you're gonna give me out today
and I hate you for we're aren't you
going flippy-flippy why don't you flippy
flooping hope Oh hot Wow no no no kiss
what's even the point now well that was
a new ver that was a maneuver that was
an uber that you chose to do if I just
oh oh right left right left right left
right left right left right left right
left right left and can see suddenly
left
yeah oh no that's a lot of glass oh hey
thanks for the blanket don't eat it now
though so let me think about this
logically there's a way to get that
furnace Oh
I see it oh I was right there there's a
thermostat where is it up there though
why is it a fear no no okay slap it with
the back of your ass oh oh oh no that's
the bad wall what the folk eh
all right honey all nailed it nailed it
very hard nailed it so go why oh I love
the rocky music by the way very
triumphant huh oh I didn't go as far as
I thought I would that's okay and
correct
uh-oh slappy oh hey okay
slappy Slappy's coming oh boy flappy
didn't want to go this way
slappy forgot about the hole how did
slappy do that
how does slappy do oh boy okay just
gonna fall into the pit and hope for the
best
yeah uh-oh please don't do that to me
but okay we're getting a little sassier
than we were in the last episode ooh
hi okay you're broken now what a joke
fragmented splat OH
nailed it I just need to get down to
that thermostat and then hopefully
that's gonna be all I need to do oh did
it right watch this s lap nice lah ah
hole there we go that's a nice die can't
move okay whatever it's fine cuz I got
it
oh and then I'm gonna OH
ah Oh Oh
[Music]
he did it he did it well oh we got an a
huh ha ha ha oh man oh boy
okay so anyway that is another episode
of I am bread that one went better and I
don't know why that one better for me
maybe I'm getting better at the game I
don't know probably not but okay you
know I got that so uh hmm so anyway that
is I am bread I did pretty well in that
so I think I can do another I think I
can and I bet the next one is gonna be a
son of a [ __ ] but this one it went well
for me I mean not great but it went well
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and uh as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]